نحن الان مع احدى الاسره هنا في منطقه
المعموره تحدثنا لديهما انهم كيف استقبلوا
هذا العيد كانت الاجابه ان هذا العيد
منقوص الاركان ليست الفرحه فيه كما كانت
في العاده السابقه مشاكل متعلقه بالتجهيز
للعيد مشاكل متعلقه بلم الشمل والتحرك من
منطقه الى اخرى معنا الان فواز وهو رب هذه
الاسره
نستطيع معه كيف كان عيدكم السلام عليكم
العيد في سندي مختلف جدا جدا من السنين
السابقه يعني اشتباكات ضرب نار التفاصيل
كده كثيره امني مختل جدا جدا في السودان
في منطقه المعموره هنا او في الجريف في
سافرت للاغاليم تركت الخارطه نهائيا
فعدد سكان بيجي بسيط جدا جدا الايات كان
معاي معاينات في عيد بعض المصلين بعد
الصلاه
نسلم على الناس في البيت فالحقيقه دي قلبت
في السنه دي
فبعض الاوضاع الامنيه دي شويه كده العيد
مختلف جدا جدا الحمد لله رب العالمين ربنا
يصلح الحال بتاعت البلاد